[Music]
the supply chain is a wreck while an
absent secretary still cashes a check
yep transportation is breaking down
while mayor pete's nowhere to be found
it's yet another biden administration
fail as petey doesn't even leave an
out-of-office email
take that dr seuss
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge defended being home on
paternity leave since mid-august while
the country's been hit with a crippling
supply chain crisis what am i talking
yep while he bottle-fed we bottlenecked
and while he brought home the bacon our
actual bacon doubled in price no joke
it's so bad cats had to make her own
hair at home
instead of buying it from school kids
worse pete offered no new solutions to
the crisis he didn't bother to announce
he'd be away nor did he appoint a temp
replacement he simply transported
himself home leaving america as
abandoned as don lemon's remaining brain
cells
he treats his job like kamala treats the
border he doesn't show up and nothing
gets done
cnn host and my nude yahtzee partner
jake tapper confronted him over this
as a cabinet secretary why didn't you
or the department of transportation make
an official announcement when you went
on parental
leave and why did you not appoint an
acting secretary while you were away
well so the way this works is there is a
deputy secretary polly trottenberg who's
doing phenomenal work and who as deputy
secretaries do can fill in when a
secretary is not available now look even
though i've been on paternity leave and
i'm proud of it obviously given the
nature of my job
when you take a job like mine you
understand and accept that you're going
to have to be available
24 7.
so yeah no one knew he'd be gone
and he only surfaced to address his
absence during a national crisis saying
it will last into next year just like
his paternity leave
who knows if he gets new kids every few
months he'll never come back to work
that's what i would do
but the real question is what happens if
you bail on work for two months
and no one notices
maybe you truly are non-essential
i wonder if his co-workers ever figured
out he was missing
supply chain's been backed up for months
we've got black friday right around the
corner i don't know what we're gonna do
honestly i'm out of ideas the only thing
i can think of is to ask secretary pete
he's got some unbelievable ideas i know
his calm demeanor really puts me at ease
i'm so glad biden picked him
joey you're a dad uh how do you feel
about two months leave uh for a guy i
mean that's he's got a high level job
he's allowed to do it but doesn't that
he does he's doing the correct thing but
it makes him a kind of a lousy leader
you know i've sat and watched a lot of
my buddies facetime their newborn
children because they were out i don't
know fighting a war yeah i mean maybe
maybe pete served in a different
military than i did i mean he did run
for president didn't have the dignity of
at least being a wounded veteran i mean
so
i don't know if he just doesn't get it
but there are millions of americans that
don't have the luxury of taking two
months off let me explain something to
you
a woman
a mother and i'm proud to say that word
makes a human
body with her own body
and birds that body you know she might
need a couple weeks to i don't know
he'll right recover
maternity leave makes a lot of sense
paternity leave being being the father
in this situation which i've done twice
now uh very proud of pretty good at it
made some made some awesome humans there
um listen we serve a different role
it's not we're not healing on maternity
leave we are getting to know our child
and when he said and if you finish that
line of the quote you just played he
talks about you know just because uh you
know i know the nature of this job so
even if that means checking an email
during a doctor's appointment bro i was
working meant checking an email during a
doctor's appointment i'd still be
employed by the marine corps like i mean
are you serious that's what you think
going to work is yeah and like you said
the biggest cell phone is you know if he
had been to work every day would
probably be right where we are right now
yeah cat uh noah knew he was gone
yeah that's pretty that wouldn't that
hurt your feelings if you were gone from
the show for two months and no one knew
yeah i'd be devastated we should try
that no
you love this story though yes i do
because i i want to be careful here
because paternity leave i'm a huge fan
of paternity leave and if my husband and
i ever have kids i'm gonna need him to
have a very long paternity leave and if
he doesn't we're gonna have to switch
i will do the paternity leave he can do
the maternity leave because honestly
babies
aren't like not that good of a hang
right right
everyone says will be different if it's
your own but i'm like yeah i know i will
have to take care of it
that's how it's different so hopefully
by then i will have an assistant that
can
devote their entire workday to
delivering breast milk to from the
office to my apartment and if i you know
i can just be a great dad you'll be uh
you'll be a great father i think i will
i think he's right to take it off but
that makes him it's like when he ran for
president
while being south bend indiana mayor he
was a terrible mayor but he thought he
would run for president maybe that's
smart but it makes him a lousy leader
well
so he got the job as secretary of
transportation and his nickname was
pothole pete yeah so
he had that he knew that he could pretty
much get away with anything and i think
pete has some stones to take yes he took
a big job and literally and literally
said okay i'm out of here for a few
months now because i adopted some kids
or you had some kids so that and he
actually is
on biden's policy of giving leave to
everybody in the country because no
business small business is going to get
on board with you hire somebody and and
then they leave no way baby two months i
respect him jimmy this is amazing to
take off two months on a job you just
started yeah it pisses me off so much
because i was a cab driver right when my
wife had the baby i was back to work the
minute maury povich said it was mine
all right
i guess i guess we're going in i guess
we're heading to laguardia
but no shame on him mayor pete shouldn't
be running a 5k let alone the
transportation department and this is
where identity politics fails the whole
country right if you appoint people
because of their bio instead of their
actual resume you get people that are in
over their head i would go out and limit
and say there's probably five million
gay americans that could fill this role
better than mayor pete but they didn't
need five americans they 5 million they
needed one guy who would drop out and
endorse biden so that's where we got but
pete booty judge running transportation
is like hunter running the dea you know
what i mean it's kind of a conflict of
interest given his background
that would be awesome just say yes
so much easier
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else